I mean you guys we are at the Honda
Center how excited are you
[Applause]
first headlining tour in the United
States so are there any nerves
performing for you know new crowds and
new Arenas like this
I feel like it was more of a good
nervous view right for us you know we
were thrilled we were like all right
because we've always wanted to tour All
Over America to see our fans in the
United States and um to finally have an
official tour it really had a lot of
meaning for us and so and a lot of
meaning for our fans too so meeting them
in person was a great experience and
even for today La we're gonna see our La
fans and we're very excited yeah it must
be exciting to walk into an arena like
this and see what the energy is like
right but I am curious like leading up
to the Big Show what's it like backstage
you guys have any like pre-show rituals
or warm-ups before you get on that stage
all right yeah we have this this chant
that we have okay all right I'll show
you commercial yeah
yo foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
-up before the warm-up okay I love it so
you're gonna perform in the UK France
Germany all for the first time do you
guys bring anything from home with you
when you're on tour
um
that's smart I like that
me too oh when I travel I gotta see like
this you know right I love it what has
been your favorite part of the tour so
far
I need to congratulate you on beatbox
because we have an English version
[Music]
why was it important for you guys to do
an English version of that song
it is
[Music]
you guys nailed it it's so good and it's
so fun and I keep thinking you know you
guys are discovering through this tour
that you really have fans all over the
world right so what does it mean to have
this Global impact with your music but
also to be able to communicate so
closely with people who might not even
speak your language
[Music]
now the music video for beatbox what's
your favorite dance move from the video
from the video
Instagram
can you show me a little bit okay
you see that I picked it up fast okay I
learned it real fast okay
I know that included some handwritten
lyrics by you guys what was the idea
behind that I mean I don't think we had
time to film a music video
I'm joking um but honestly we didn't
really want to just have a lyric video
without something that we kind of
Incorporated our actual feelings into it
something personal something personal
and something that actually came
directly from us and so um we didn't
even write it all together we were in
separate places but we kind of got the
message that we had it right and we
wanted to write something that would be
in the lyric video and uh we kind of
decorated it as much as we could and um
I think it came out really cute in a way
and um I think that's what lyric videos
are worth watching for yeah if you know
what I mean like it's not just fonts and
like words but like to have actual art
and like telling creative Aesthetics and
stuff
[Music]
I want to play a quick game with you
guys okay I want to know who takes the
longest to get ready one two three
hey but look it paid off right look at
how handsome he is
I love it okay so who's always on time
three two three no
um
for this tour I feel like it was
actually for this tour who's always
singing he's always singing all right
okay ready one two three
as you can see it's probably all of you
guys you guys all sing right okay I like
this one who's on their phone the most
oh okay this is easy all right okay
ready one two three
wow
uh are you on your phone yeah yeah
that's okay that's okay and then finally
who has the best style do you think okay
okay ready one two three
I love my style yeah he said I love my
songs
I gotta say I think you guys are all
very stylish okay and also I just love
the love you guys do everything at the
top of your game so congratulations
[Music]
thank you